en su contexto es el juego de las sillas
para el gobierno de emanuel macrón tras
perder la mayoría absoluta en las
elecciones legislativas del pasado mes
de cara al nuevo mandato el presidente
francés tiene que forjar alianzas para
gobernar y buscar mayorías distintas
para cada iniciativa legislativa
lo que requerirá es mucha negociación
tratarán de atraer a la derecha para
algunas leyes y a la izquierda para
otras y esperar que todo vaya bien
para desbloquear la situación este lunes
el presidente macrón anunció la
reestructuración del gobierno los cargos
principales permanecen intactos como la
cartera de exteriores de finanzas y de
interior
pero otros ministros han sido
reemplazados o trasladados a otras
funciones el cambio más destacado es la
destitución de damián abad
investigado por violación que deja el
ministerio de la solidaridad y parece
preferible
pareció preferible frente a esta
siniestra campaña débil de formación que
tengo que ser capaz de defenderme sin
interferir en el trabajo del gobierno
otros movimientos notables incluyen al
ex ministro de salud olivier verán que
ha sido nombrado portavoz del ejecutivo
y clement don hasta ahora ministro de
asuntos europeos pasa a liderar el
ministerio de transportes finalmente
ninguno de los nuevos ministros viene de
partidos externos y los analistas
señalan que los cambios no son
significativos
ni hay grandes anuncios ni grandes
figuras de otros partidos no hay nuevas
alianzas no es un gobierno de coalición
se espera que la primera ministra
pronuncia su discurso protocolario el
miércoles pero no se someterá a un voto
de confianza del parlamento